-Guys, let's do a couple
thank-you notes.
You guys, is that okay?
Let's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, last week of January.
Or as all my resolutions put it,
"Well, there's always 2023."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do it next year.
-Come on, man.
Don't be so hard on yourself.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, bomb cyclone, for
sounding less like a snowstorm
and more like what happens when
you pour 151 in a McFlurry.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's my jam.
-[ Slurps ]
[ Smacks lips ]
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, meteorologist who
said this weekend's winter storm
could bring snow anywhere
between 2 and 20 inches.
[ Laughter ]
Or as the guy who's coming
to install my cable put it,
the student
has become the master.
[ Applause ]
Anywhere between
2 and 20 inches.
Okay.
Thank you for nothing.
-Or 60 inches.
We just don't know.
-150 inches of snow.
Or noth--
Or it could be dusting,
a slight dusting.
-Or it could get real hot.
-It could get hot, as well.
It could, yeah.
I just wanted to tell you,
give you a heads-up.
-On what?
-Goodbye.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, Boris Johnson,
for lying about throwing parties
during the pandemic.
Though, to be fair --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Though, to be fair, it's pretty
hard to lie about partying
when you always look
like you just woke up
from a three-day whiskey bender.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A little crispy today.
-2 to 20?
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, Cincinnati Bengals
versus Kansas City Chiefs
this weekend, or as it's known
to tailgaters,
chili versus barbecue.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, that's right.
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you,
Minnie Mouse's new pantsuit,
for causing
way too much controversy
considering one of her friends
has never worn pants.
I mean, come on.
Hey, come on.
[ Applause ]
-Come on.
-[ Donald Duck voice ]
I don't know.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, metal cage
that goes around the cork,
for making my prosecco feel
like it's Harry Houdini.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Pops lips ]
Thank you, Little Caesars'
new Batman Calzony,
for giving every pizza
delivery guy a great excuse
for when they deliver
a crushed box.
They go, "No, no,
it's the Batman Calzony."
There you have it.
Those are our thank-you notes.